good to see you it's a tradition unlike
any other where we have players come on
and read their draft profiles now we of
course take out the positives so only
the negatives will be read just like not
negative okay now I don't negative
select no no just to let you know we've
done this with future hall-of-famers you
know Drew Brees
JJ Watt but I blame the down ads here
they think that this is really funny to
see you guys squirm when you're reading
the draft profiles it's only hasn't been
as long as it's been for those guys
those guys has been probably close to
like 10 years since they've read these
is yeah like three four years ago for me
do you remember at what point did you
say I can play in the NFL it never
crossed my mind that I had that I wasn't
going to be some type of professional
athlete as a kid as like growing up I
always had success on the on the field
on the court in the rink at whatever
sporting playground I was at so it was
it was never a question of whether or
not I could be it was whether or not I
did the things I had to do to get where
I needed to be
how much is confidence and how much is
cocky or arrogance I feel like it's all
confidence I mean I feel like with
confidence comes a little bit of
arrogance and that's just you know the
competitor in me I feel like is I feel
like I'm I know what I'm capable of
doing and I don't think anyone can
really get in the way of me doing it but
did I go how you want I guess but what
happens during a game when it's there's
this conversation that goes on but can
you just fend it off as conversation or
does any of it start to bite a little
bit that you want to go back at somebody
I mean yeah it's under your skin what
gets under my skin is when I don't make
the plays so if I if I drop a book drop
a pass then I'm all man if next next
time somebody pushes me I'm going to
that's going to get under my skin
because now I'm already yeah drop in the
passage that already looks bad and then
I don't know it's just it's just all
crappy situation but what if I say
something to you like yeah nice catch
Pro Bowler I look at you and say thanks
happy yet appreciate that
I'll see you wouldn't engage with
somebody um no I'm not I'm not the one
to go after you if you're going to talk
to me I'll talk back but
I'm not the one that's just going to go
straight forward and go right at your
jugular start talking about your mother
what once the last time you got into one
of those um I'm just like probably
Indianapolis Colts I couldn't even tell
you the guys name is defensive lineman
for him
you got into over the defensive lineman
yeah yeah exactly like what happened
what we were just do the blocking the
entire game trying to be the physical
more physical guy coming off the ball
and you just start the exchange where'd
you said I wasn't that type of player
I'm not the blocking type I said I'd
well when we run in next time to you
know make a tackle brother obviously in
a different form of language but other
than that yeah that's why I go what do
people say to you on the street um
what's the number-one thing you hear the
number-one thing is did I find love on
the show yeah and no I did not find love
on the show did you expect to find love
on your reality show you know there was
the hope were you did you find cash on
your and ended up being a nice nice yes
yes yes that's found cash I don't even
know what to say that yes does the
league have to approve that reality show
no why they didn't River but I didn't
even I didn't ask for their proven but
now other yeah yeah permission
permission approval improvement okay who
was more uncomfortable watching it in
your fam my dad probably I don't the
only thing my dad watched it I think he
might have like saw like the opening
line that I won right there I think he
saw that and was just I all right I'm
done really yeah why would your dad be
embarrassed by um I feel like this show
shows a different side of really not
necessarily who I am but not every day
you see a guy talk you know intimate to
a lady sorry
multiple ladies did these
knowing the our living what's that did
they know what you did for a living
um if they didn't know before they knew
like right in the beginning okay yeah I
mean I was there were some motives
behind there I guess I don't know
did anybody get to wear your Jersey um
not my game jerseys now nobody threw the
game Jersey on oh there might have been
something that through some 87 is on the
back of shooters you know and
represented the 87 but that are you
gonna do it again no I'm not a chance ah
not a chance
I'm stick to it all football and
catching up with Old Spice speaking of
it look at you look at the pitch man
here travis joins us on behalf of old
spies hardest-working collection
performance here so fire away given our
hardest-working collection indeed that's
ours wearing collectible has been around
for a year it's been around for a year
and this year they're coming out with
the the hydro wash little steel courage
really bring the courage of body and
keep you fresh moisturizing hydrated
it's kind of a Ron Burgundy delivery I
got for you you know yeah I got a little
Ron in me you ever been around somebody
in the pile of smells man um yes
actually I don't know why this just came
to my head I was actually at the when
the Cavaliers won then the parade was
around Cleveland I was walking around
Cleveland just because I'm a big
Cleveland fanatic and everything just
ever since I was a little kid and I was
walking around and I mean it was it was
like just a pile of crap was just
hanging around right in front of me the
entire time and I was just like I do I
hope that's not me I am like like
smelling myself every like two minutes
like his attainted I could have been
Timothy Moscow ya know he's hanging it
up um yeah now what we once we cleared
through all the all the garbage that I
found out it wasn't me and that actually
somebody crapped their pants on the way
that'd be the Golden State Warriors who
did that Old Spice you can lift it it's
a smell legendary smells oh this smells
delicious
yes Old Spice on You Tube page you can
see more with the Travis there all right
I want you to here is your draft profile
actual these were actual things written
about you all right now the bottom line
is the positive okay but I want you to
read it
oh I'm greater eating it's at Cincinnati
Bearcats all right weakness only one
season of production in college doesn't
have blazing speed you talk about ATR to
the house Merry Christmas whoever wrote
that oh come on not a tremendously
explosive athlete doesn't come out of
his brakes that well hmm not a
tremendous but still an athlete Kells
plays with the pedal to the metal which
isn't always a good thing
must be that steel courage he doesn't
run a wide variety of routes doesn't
display sudden or sharp breaks and
routes character is a big question
he doesn't really produce until 2012 so
may label him a potential one-year
wonder ooh the old one-hit wonders how
much it is anything true in there um I
want to say no but I mean it's
somebody's opinion so I mean I can't say
it it's completely false right
I mean someone someone see something on
film you know it's a it's rather a
raised question about it than the not
raised question about it but um favorite
why he isn't a tremendous athlete hurts
my feelings
because I feel like I'm pretty high up
there on the athlete list it went least
at least in the tight end group that's
what I'm putting this into favorite
white guy cliche white receiver cliche
dude okay I'm one I mean obviously you
got the white men can't jump
um sneaky fast nobody sneaky fast the
trihard white guy you know the guy that
just found his way in the league from
trying harder than the guy crossover
high motor i motor guy yeah deceptively
athletic deceptively how do you hide
your athletic like you're trying to hide
the athleticism I don't don't tell
anybody but I'm going 80 yards here
deceptively athletic
that's pretty I don't know who came up
with that one where do you where do you
feel like if we're looking at tight ends
everybody's playing everybody's healthy
it's Grunk the best tight end in
football um I feel like the stats in the
the arm field play takes care all that I
can't really say who's the best of the
best I feel like I'm the best on the
field I feel I give my team the best
opportunity to win when I'm on the field
wouldn't you do better than drunk I
think when I get the ball in my hands
I'm just a different type of athlete
grunts the guy that's going to run
around there like a Clydesdale man he's
just gonna run through and everything
just just a big like Boulder and I uh
I'm more of a guy that can make it make
somebody miss I feel like that can break
somebody down with with the Juke mover
or kind of just slide off tacklers
guards more of a guy that breaks through
everything who's more all bro you or
drunk man throwing the throne the meat
at Gronk wow man you're a great guy
you're great guys I think Ron's a hell
of a player may about like I said I feel
like I'm the me roll bro I'm the play
I'm the best tight end in the league and
um you know this is different
until everyone agrees with that I'll
keep working my tail off but this is all
bro no bro yeah y'all you put a B in
there yeah I don't care about the
pronoun CH yeah that one Oh
all bro oh man that's that's even better
question
golly gonna have to really think about
that I think crock might take it in the
end the bro yes falling yeah we crunched
the numbers 2012 grok was first team all
bro Travis took over the title last year
really all bro tied in Crocs calmed it
down a lot he hiding yeah he's matured
bill bills over there thing is anything
you could be a patriot I'm not very good
I'm very good with it taken between the
lines there so more from Travis the Old
Spice hardest-working collection of
course it's a white guy hardest-working
crime working day what you did with that
you see that the lasting sent the ultra
superior hydration it's not just
superior hydration this is ultra
superior later we dig into the science
okay and they get in tight drove wash
body wash wait why is it just called
hydro body wash why is that the hydro
wash body wash because the hydro wash is
what makes it the body wash you see the
different marbling in the key ring in a
bottle it goes from white to blue the
blue is actually the hydration so that's
the hydro wash and then the white is
what actually cleanse you and keeps you
moisturize crazy stuff I don't know how
it works I just know that it works you
want to pop somebody what you want to
pop somebody during the break what yeah
somebody wanted to take a splash we
would what Paulie wouldn't mind like
mclovin I want trying to keep you off
the line is if we are like oh yeah no
I'm hanging you okay with it
alright believe I'm going anywhere okay
all right I'm hang you got no brunch you
got no place to go home I mean if you
send my second instance right now mango
dan yeah we're not scared we read that
he wasn't athletic so he's it is
accurate Wow if Gronk was here you
wouldn't do it no yeah you know what the
crab make my night off you inside itself
maybe Travis can help you
McLovin is trying to learn how to be a
wide receiver here okay
oh I thought I think you're gonna say
help me with charissa coming on Friday
with some hydro wash body wash no smell
steel cutters I shouldn't have gone to
your right
I should have ended it right there I
will come back Travis Kelce here if
you're watching on audience Channel 239
DirecTV the NBC Sports Network it was a
clinic
paulien McLovin trying to keep Travis
Kelce from catching a pass it was futile
absolutely futile yes both he is
deceptively athletic I had no idea he's
been trying to hide that athleticism for
a while this is the first time he
brought it out did you get hurt
don't even try we're doing spin class
here in an hour and these guys are
trying to bail on spin class today oh
don't you see it's on it's still the
beginning of the week you can't bail
beginning you're going to bail at the
end of the week Pauly's you could hurt
I'm buttery soft you give me a little
under hook to the ribcage area oh yeah
no that's what I call the leverage point
it's crazy you can get really can get
real you know was it I don't even know
it incuse real technical in terms of the
anatomy of the body which way you throw
somebody else where can you go blank
look part of the body like a dealership
back so you got yours you got your
basically what they call the core of
your body in the middle you got all this
and you got your four limbs that tip the
body a certain way your your balance
beams almost so if you get one of those
off balance something else has to
trigger to regain that balance so if I
lift this shoulder something on the back
end has to be able to anchor down on the
ground something up you know you have to
do a lot of things so guys try and get
under under under each other and trying
to like push the leverage shoulders and
and even when you're like double teaming
somebody in a block you want to push
their hips you want to get their their
their core off-balance you can get up
and move them did you grow up the
Cleveland Browns fence yes I did and
then they they they sent a team away to
Baltimore and I just became overall
football fanatic really sports fanatic
at that but for the most part it was it
was Cleveland growing up I had my Bernie
Kosar get up as a kid and it was a yes
it's Cleveland I mean if you're not a
Browns fan in Cleveland you're uh you're
in trouble but did they did they break
your heart when they moved and therefore
you didn't forget I remember I remember
going down to a Municipal Stadium when I
was a kid and it was like the last fan
appreciation day me and the family went
down and we grabbed seats from the
Stadium brought him back to the house
it's pretty cool were you supposed to
take the seats back yeah no they were
turned over okay idea I was like are
everybody to take Smith ya know is it
you know just little prissy who see you
and Britt see who do we have on the show
tomorrow
we've got von Miller coming on Josh
Norman Dan Marino Michael Irvin and the
Texans cheerleaders also got to swing by
to give us a couple of tips as we get
ready to a lineup yeah not a bad line up
there
my thanks to everybody who showed up
today Travis Kelce with the Old Spice
hardest-working like guy collection
performance lineup and the lasting scent
I don't think it's officially called
that though that's what we're calling
Old Spice hardest-working white guy
collection performance the Dan Patrick
show weekday morning on audience
[Music]